it's a Heidi Halloween
[Music]
Heidi Klum and boyfriend Tom Cowlitz
share some PDA on Halloween oh all good
comedy critter I always get a lot of
kisses but maybe I get more kisses today
the couple stepped out Wednesday night
on All Hallows Eve for Heidi's annual
bash in New York City as an uncanny
version of Shrek and Princess Fiona
that's pretty special
especially that I finally found my Shrek
I kinda always wanted to be Fiona but I
never had the track to do it with it is
a suite that he's actually doing this
I've done this many times doing
prosthetics and all of this stuff so for
him to go through that it's pretty
phenomenal
earlier in the day Heidi shared the
couple's almost 10 hour transformation
on social media
[Music]
I'm told but it's fun it's fun I come
very hear anything that can talk but
it's fun I had to start it in the past
but nothing like this no the only place
I can still sort of recognize him
obviously are his eyes but it's it's
difficult which is you in there
I don't have a suit on or me I don't
work for this
the secret is I'm going to have to help
you to go to the bathroom because I
don't think he can find his thing under
that
[Music]